so tell us about the characters in amber
and also the diversity that you want to
incorporate into them well you know I
really think and I'm glad you noticed
that because diversity is one of the
things that I'd like to hang my hat on
as a filmmaker because I think with a
Hollywood because they're in a comfort
zone and they're there you know it's a
product for them films or a product and
the it's just what it is that's the
business that they're in and because it
is a product they're not as I I'd say
daring with some of their character
choices because they like to stick with
something that they've succeeded with in
the past so I think that kind of makes
them a little less a daring when it
comes to choosing characters and making
characters for films and I think that's
one of the things that's going to be
different about amber it's a true let's
take him for instance he's one of the co
stars in the film he actually is a guy
who the lead character Marcus vines
hanging out on the corner rolling dice
drinking beers with his friends and uh
Marcus has his reaction just like you
would have just like I would have
driving into cars like there's a bunch
of big guys roll the dice on the corner
drinking I'm gonna keep going and it's
the desperation of that Marcus is in its
the timeline that is in where he only
has he has no one big where to go he
tries to go to the sheriff to tell him
where he's found this child where these
guys are holding this kid and the
sheriff tries to kill him so basically
leaves Marcus no choice he needs to get
help and he has to get it from someone
so he goes and approaches these guys and
troop is one of the guys and truth is
basically he's going to be like an onion
in this film he unravels like an onion
maybe when you first see him you'd say
yeah I got that guy pegged I know who he
is tattoos on him he's a gangbanger he's
just adding the other and you could put
him in the box and you you what most
people do and he's one of those guys
that tends to unravel them as he speaks
as you learn them the situations tend to
pull him out and reveal who he is and it
becomes much more than just what you see
on the surface and I think that's what I
want people to kind of come away with
from this film you know that you are
maybe
just give a person a little second or
two a bit more of an open mind before
you judge them and put them in that box
and say that that's all that they can be
and I think that's what I'm going to be
one of the stronger points about this
film is the different characters that
I've chosen in certain to this project
where were some of the composites for
these characters or inspirations for
these characters where these based on
people maybe who met at the club I'm
sure you probably ran into so many
fascinating oh yeah there's definitely
some characters that remind us some
Muslim characters in the club but uh
initially the three characters in this
film are they're actually kinda I think
in some ways you know without over
analyzing myself I think there are three
facets of myself you know because I came
from a rough neighborhood in Queens and
uh you know at times I you know it
wasn't necessarily gang activity but you
get peer pressure to you know do certain
things with groups and I joined groups
and do things that you think of wrong
and stuff like that and at times you
know I had to step away and deal with
the repercussions of that but you have
to be true to you who you yourself and
do what you believe in so at times that
were friction from that so to me that
first stage in my life where I had to
deal with peer pressure and things like
that is Marcus in markets as a character
who gets out of a rough neighborhood he
gets beat up all the time for not
joining gangs but he never joins the
gang and he gets beat up his entire high
school year he ends up moving becomes a
high-level executive he goes to come and
he he finds himself in a good place in
life because of his determination now
the truth and now our troupe is a guy
who came from a rough neighborhood but
he chose to stay in that rough
neighborhood and he's a very intelligent
guy who takes care of his younger sister
lost his mother you know when they were
young and he just happens he's kind of
like the father figure in the
neighborhood so you know even though
there's criminals and rough guys around
them they all tend to look up to him and
then you have our third character who is
uh detective Morgan and again grew up in
a rough neighborhood but he wanted to
change the neighborhood that he grew up
in so he became a cop and you know a
vice cop and things like that he had 15
years in the force and then
15 years of failed marriage and
everything like that he looks back and
he sees the neighborhood getting worse
so now he ends up with a resentment bit
towards you know gangbangers or anyone
who looks like it and then he also has a
resentment towards guys like Marcus who
came from the neighborhood but it seems
to have left and left everybody behind
so you get these three different
characters who came from very similar
backgrounds who found their way out of
them in different ways but now they've
kind of got these resentments and it
tends to hold them back from doing the
right thing in this film but eventually
you know the characters have to learn to
trust each other get over these past
grievances and resentments towards each
other and do what's right just save the
kids have your kids there let's not
bring that's what brings them all
together so you can save their one
little child it's an action film but to
me is it's much more than that it's it's
a character-driven story that just
happens to have action
you